drop the knife drop the knife
how are you can you just put the knife
down for me please it's the police
department my name's officer how you
doing
it's it's off he just put the Knife Down
it's okay
you guys have one of your bean bags just
in case
it's okay
how are you
kill yourself
okay I'm here to help you can you just
put the knife down and we can figure out
we can just figure it all out we'll get
you some help
do can you not see me
hey why don't you uh can we guys move my
light so I can see that I'm a place yeah
yeah it's okay
and I'll come to you but can I just have
you drop a knife
what do you mean what do I need to do to
get you to drop the knife
enough
that's me that's my
okay I can back up for you
I'm having trouble hearing you so that's
that's
what's up sir
yeah
my name I'm a police officer
to the Sacramento Police Department
uh no he he could go away he could go
away don't worry about it don't worry
about him
can you just put the knife down just
please put the Knife Down
if you could just give me a huge favor
just put the knife down okay
I know but it would make me feel so much
better if you would put the knife down
okay
can you please do that for me
no no no no I don't want no no please we
don't want anything bad to happen please
don't
so can you just like put it on the
ground
I'm I'm willing to talk to you sir as
much as you want
I'll stay right here I can I I just I
just can't hear you that's the only one
problem
yes sir
yep
can you go talk to them away I can't
hear him
what's up sir
I apologize the officers are talking too
loud I can't hear them I want to hear
what you have to say
why are you doing that
well
can you do me a favor though
so what what
how can I get you to put the Knife Down
yeah
I I I'm just standing right here
that's all it is
I'm just standing right here if if you
put the knife down you can come out to
us just I don't I you can don't come
near us if you have the knife okay
well because they're concerned for you
because you have a knife
well how can I help you
like what can I do to help you to make
that day better
what's that
I don't want to hurt you sir that's the
absolute last thing I want to happen
foreign
I can move the light
no I don't want we don't We're not gonna
do that that's not we don't want that to
happen that is not that's sir that's the
last thing that's gonna happen right now
while continuing to verbally Engage The
Suspect officer number one began to
verify officers were in place with less
lethal tools
while confirming these assignments
officer number one learned that the
victim was still locked in a bathroom
inside the residence from a family
member who was on scene talking to the
victim on a cell phone
officer number one checked on the
feasibility of having the victim exit
the residence through a window which was
not possible
where do you feel comfortable that you
can
uh you can adequately apply some bean
bag less lethal to him if he comes out
tonight okay no what is your line of
demarcation that's my question to you
what is your decision
probably about
okay if he comes at us or you feel
comfortable with doing that yeah yeah
okay
make sure you communicate if he
continues to advance on us we'll do that
hey uh can you come over here
you come up so I just if he's got a
knife I don't want us to be separated so
we have but once you come around to us
what what I apologize so I'm missing
like
oh we will leave like I have no problem
with that but my concern is people here
are worried about you because you're
walking around with a knife that's
what's that that's fireworks
yeah
well it's yeah we're getting closer
Fourth of July
so where's that awesome
my concern is
we're separated right
no there's more people inside them
because he made
okay
how old is your you said your mother
she's 84 is she able to move like well
because I want to know her level of
Mobility if I have we could pour out of
a window that kind of thing
I don't want that because no no let's
make sure she's barricaded the door if
she so he can't get out into there
is there like but just do not let do not
have her go outside the bathroom
let's just keep her in there okay
well that changes this
well I did not know there was anywhere
no no I'm trying to I can't hear it
well let's keep talking to him if we
keep his attention to us
if he makes a movement to force his way
in there with a knife
right now
as long as he keeps talking to us that
we can try to get key escalate to uh
I just
took them
Hey sir sir hi
I never got your name
drop the knife drop the knife
hey come to me
he knows she's in there hey pal we just
want to chat with you
because I love God it's my God I know
but we don't want to hurt you please
just come out just drop the knives oh
yeah yeah
he goes forward
he's got two knives in his hand I think
now hey we need some more help officer
don't leave us
Hey sir just please put the knives down
fucking myself no
no
yeah let's marry up yeah
hey pal come on
Sarge what's your decision if he goes
towards the bathroom again what are we
gonna do are we gonna use less lethal
yeah
hey come here come here sir don't go
over there come here sir come on out
come on
come on okay so let's go let's go let's
go sir sir
get in there get in there get in there
foreign
[Applause]